(Baby babbling)
(Crowd chattering)
(Typewriter clunking)
(Scratch of pen on paper)
Language.
It's how we express ourselves, inspire, connect.
Language has helped our society evolve.
Where there is human experience
experience there is language.
What if we can find insights in all that
speech and all that text that's around us?
Modern computing is now reaching the power to
process human language. From capabilities
like universal translation to
summarizing legal documents and even
understanding human emotion. We're just
beginning to explore the possibilities.
That's why we've developed the natural
language processing Nanodegree program.
Master the skills that are changing the
world. You'll build a github portfolio of
projects with machine translation, neural
networks, and speech recognition.
Because when you teach computers to not just
understand language but to actually
generate new communication, you can help
take the human experience to
a whole new level.
Join us at Udacity and get started with NLP!